♪ ♪ ♪
- À quelques jours du scrutin,
l'une des dernières occasions
pour la coalition des partis de
droite de séduire les Italiens.
♪ ♪ ♪
Sur scène, l'ancien premier
ministre conservateur Silvio
Berlusconi, le chef de la Ligue,
formation d'extrême droite,
Matteo Salvini, mais dans la
foule, certains sont arrivés des
heures d'avance pour entendre
l'autre membre de la coalition.
- ... Primera Donna.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Celle qui aspire à devenir
la première femme à diriger
le pays, Giorgia Meloni,
dirigeante de Fratelli d'Italia,
"les frères d'Italie".
- Giorgia Meloni dirige un parti
décrit comme post-facste,
hériter des formations
politiques qui ont suivi
la Deuxième Guerre mondiale et
la chute de Benito Mussolini.
(en italien)
Un dictateur pour
la politicienne ne cachait pas
son admiration dans ses débuts
en politique, comme en témoigne
ce reportage réaliplus
de 25 ans.
GIORGIA MELONI, candidate,
Frères d'Italie
- Moi, je crois que Mussolini,
c'était un bon politicien.itici.
C'est-à-dire que tout ce qu'il a
fait, il l'a fait pour l'Italie.
- Giorgia Meloni dans
la formation arrive en tête
des intentions de vote tente
donc de prendre ses distances de
tage et de polir son
image. Une campagne menée
notamment ici en Italie, mais
aussi ailleurs en Europe avec
la publication de vidéos en
plusieurplusieurplusieurplusieut
le français.
- J'ai lu que la victoire de
Fratelli d'Italia aux électi
de septembre conduirait à
un désastre, à un tournant
autoritaire, à la sortie de
l'Italie de l'euro.
Rien de tout cela .
FRANCESCO MASELLI, correspondant
à Rome, L'Opinion
- Il y a un cadre de parti,
un militant de parti qui a fait
le salut romain; donc le salut
fasciste en funérailles, donc
en pleine campagne électorale.
Donc ça, ça se voit. S'ils
sont... ils sont en difficulté à
cacher ça.
- Mais pour cet observateur de
la vie publique italienne,
le passé de Giorgia Meloni ne
nuit pas nécessairement à cette
politicienne qui a fait son
entrée au parlement en 2006.
- Il faut dire aussi
qu'elle a déjà participé à un
gouvernement. Donc,
ça montre quand même qu'on a
déjà banalisé les postes
fascistes dans les années 80.
En 1994, Silvio Berlusconi,
il fait ement avec
les postfascistes, donc en fait,
c'est déjà normalisé. On n'est
pas du tout dans une nouveauté.
- Guido Crosetto a justement
fait partie des gouvernements
Berlusconi, comme sous
secrétaire à la Défense.
Avec Giorgia Meloni, il est
l'un des cofondateurs
des Frères d'Italie.
"Mussolini et le facisme sont
morts", dit-il.
Cet homme qui connaît très bien
Giorgia Meloni assure qu'elle
est différente d'autres figures
de la droite radicale européenne
comme Marine Le Pen.
"Elle cOTAN,OTAN,OTAN,OTAN,OTA,
en l'Alliance Atlantique et
elle est impliquée dans l'Union
européenne."
En campagne, Giorgia Meloni a
beaucoup parlé d'inflation et
d'énergie, tout en abordant des
thèmes chers aux partisans de
l'extrême droite, comme
l'immigration et sécurité.
Cet élu du Parti démocrate
dénonce un mélange de
radicalisme et d'inexpérience au
sein des troupes d
À son avis, la coalition de
droite serait néfaste pour
l'Italie et l'Europe
Il déplore un manque de
cohérence sur les sanctions et
la question ukrainienne
parce que si Meloni s'est
montrée critique de la Russie,
c'est loin d'être le cas de
certains de ses partenaires
d'autres partis.
♪ ♪ ♪
Les Italiens se prononceront
bientôt. Selon les sondages,
Giorgia Meloni, figure
d'opposition depuis plusieurs
années, pourrait bien gagner son
pari. Peu importe les résultats,
la politicienne ressort de cette
campagne avec encore plus de
notoriété. Tout indique qu'elle
contribuera à donner le rythme
de la vie politique italienne.
♪ ♪ ♪
Ici Raphaël Bouvier-Aucl